[Applaudissements]
beaucoup de spectateurs bien sûr avec
est ce pour ça c'était la semaine passée
lorsqu'ils ont gagné mais il y aura du
monde comme ça ce soir également avec
nous frank pons qui est le doyen notre
culte et des sciences de
l'administration de l'université laval
directeur de l'observatoire
international en management du sport
bonsoir alors ça veut dire quoi d'abord
sur le plan économique c'est un match
serré dînatoire avec beaucoup pas
beaucoup de spectateurs ça veut dire
quoi un âge de syrie ça veut dire
beaucoup de revenus en théorie on est
dans une situation très particulière
tout cas ce soir à vegas va y avoir
beaucoup de revenus pour le canadien de
montréal si on était dans une situation
normale on remplit l'aréna où tous les
gens consomment les derniers chiffres
qu'on a c'est autour de 7 millions de
dollars de revenus pour des gros matchs
en séries h abattu en ituri par match
pour une équipe et à montréal et ça date
un peu plus parce que vous savez on n'a
pas fait les séries beaucoup dans les
dernières années mais les impacts
économiques sont assez importants aussi
au niveau de la ville à 3,4 millions de
dollars aussi pour tout ce qui est
revenu généralement de dépenses dans les
bars d'ailleurs ce une bonne nouvelle ce
soir je pense pour les tenanciers de
bars comme les ouverture élargie mais ça
c'est habituellement avec la pandémie
mais vous comprenez elle annonce qui a
été faite aujourd'hui vous souvenez vous
venez d'en parler de dogmatisme hommes
de spectateurs oui ça ferait du bien aux
joueurs ça ferait du bien aux canadiens
aussi parce qu'il ya des revenus qui
sont laissés sur la table quand on a
juste 2500 spectateurs
mais jusqu'à quel point si on devait
augmenter parce que la décision n'est
pas prise encore mais si on passe de
2500 à 5000 ou a dit mais je ne sais pas
quelle est l'importance pour le canadien
sur le plan des revenus d'avoir plus de
gens dans les gradins est énorme quand
vous avez vous diront qu athlète à
capacité on multiplie le nombre de
spectateurs par quatre cinq six sept
dépendamment de la taille des appareils
vous voyez que l'on va arriver à des
montagnes sur le vif par les 2,7
millions de dollars qu'à la rédac plein
donc là on est à une infime partie de ce
qu'on peut faire parce qu il ya des
revenus additionnels qui sont des
revenus publicitaires et autres
mais la grande partie de consommation et
de billetterie mais pas là et donc on
n'est pas au niveau de revenus escomptés
par contre en terme de construction de
la marque c'est très important pour le
canadien
avec dans les dernières années il ya eu
de nombreux dvd déboires au niveau
sportif mais aussi beaucoup critiqué
l'image de marque du canadien et là tout
est oublié tout le monde est un amour
c'est la beauté du sport aussi donc une
avancée dans les séries a aussi en plus
des revenus économiques des impacts à
long terme pour la marque serait
attribue la marque du canadien à l'heure
actuelle actuelle qu'elle est là vous
parlez de marque pour la ligue nationale
quelle est la valeur d'un affrontement
entre une équipe récentes comme las
vegas jeune dynamique très spectaculaire
et une équipe plus traditionnelle à la
longue histoire comme le canadien a bien
si tu sais la bataille parfaite vous
savez on a on a enterré
las vegas très rapidement notamment à
québec qu'une cellule expansion et qu'on
aurait voulu avoir une équipe à québec
une équipe au milieu du désert on
comprenait pas bien si vous regardez les
stratégies marketing le lien à la
communauté à las vegas est une réussite
ils ont une stratégie de 2 lié à la
communauté qui est très très importante
dans un milieu qui n'est pas évident où
le haut qui ne fait pas partie de la
culture mais ils ont réussi en quelques
années à développer un attachement très
très fort à diversifier leurs revenus
ils sont immondes dans les classements
valeur annuelle de la franchise et donc
c'est une marque descente et c'est
quelque part moyen pour les nationales
de montrer que leur expansion ont du
succès aussi au niveau sportif en plus
du côté commercial et c'est intéressant
de voir cette lutte d'opposition d'une
marque comme le canadien qu'une marque
établie très forte qui avoue qui vit en
fait sur son histoire qui a besoin de se
renouveler aussi et les gérer la marque
agressive beaucoup plus jeunes dans des
stratégies marketing très innovante
aussi que sont les golden knights donc
bel affrontement aussi au niveau
marketing à voir là la mise en marché de
ces deux produits là dedans des comptes
est différent il faut suivre les médias
sociaux des golden knights pour
comprendre la dynamique qui est
complètement différente de du canadien
par exemple ou d'autres d'autres
organisations est ce que la ligue
franck pense souhaite une finale toute
américaine vegas new york par exemple
enders où ce serait plus intéressant
pour la ligue et même sur le plan
financier final canado-américaine new
york ou tampa bay contre le canadien
ça serait la ligue la ligue n'a pas de
préférence officiellement pas ce talent
et visuellement m revenant mais va
mettre en marche et la finale comme elle
le ferait vous savez il ya plein de
manières de tourner les la rivalité ça
peut être la rivalité du sud si c'est
sympa comme les gones
ça peut être la crise la rivalité de
l'est avec le canadien comme thailand's
il faut toujours trouver un moyen de le
présenter mais c'est intéressant d'avoir
cet affrontement canado-américain parce
que parce que le hockey et la pérennité
du hockey au canada
hazen a été mise en doute en termes de
visibilité par la ligue on a perdu une
équipe avec avec les nordiques ya
quelques années on a des équipes qui ont
été en difficulté aussi et on pose la
question de se dire baisse que c'est
profitable d'avoir une équipe au canada
où il allait on le voit avec les mets
police même si l'opa de succès sportifs
on le voit avec le canadien il ça serait
bien pour la ligue qui est cette
rivalité canado américaine qui se
perpétue pour montrer que le hockey mais
c'est partout le hockey c'est dans tous
les états unis
et c'est bien entendu au canada de
manière historique et on l'espère aussi
de manière victorieuse dans les jours à
venir faire vos prédictions pour la
série ben oui mais c'est plus je suis
trop bien eu de ce côté là c'est ce que
je prends pour le canadien moi aussi je
revis des choses qu'on n'a pas vécu
peut-être la dernière fois qu'on les a
vécus avec les browsers ou n'y avait
peut-être pas d'attachement au départ
maintenant leur épopée en tout cas année
beaucoup d'attachement envers la marque
lors vis avec le canadien plus un fan
des nordiques jusqu'à même avant mais je
prends pour le canadien donc j'espère
que le canadien a gagné la coupe stanley
en attendant le retour des nordiques
transport et ça c'est beaucoup
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
on